we're here in what Spencer PV calls the
rainforests of home he's been working on
the rainforests in Latin America and
elsewhere finally realized that having
grown up in Portland Oregon he's a
fifth-generation or going in yet his own
reforest work about worried about Anna
work on and so as you see in the
introduction and the card has been on
the case with ecotrust for quite a while
now I've got some we have for sale
outside stuff about ecotrust and from
ecotrust as we have stuff from the long
now foundation not because either his
talk are these talks are promotion for
those organizations but those
organizations give you some idea of the
sort of body of thinking that goes into
of the series of talks for the long now
and dispensers talk for tonight I'm
particularly pleased to get someone
local and we're doing this from time to
time because what tends to happen with
big lectures is you get somebody from
far away and they're very exotic and as
they say an expert is an ordinary guy
away from home and what we're trying to
do is is often pull up people who are
taken all over the world to hold forth
about things that they're developing
right here in California and on the west
coast and that's very much the case with
with Spencer now these cards most of you
are familiar with how it works on the
back is a place to write a question if
you have at any time during the talk
hand it to someone with one of the
yellow hats walking up and down they'll
be brought up to me you're Kevin Kelly
and we'll have a look at them and try to
get the best ones up to two bear Spencer
with if you put your name on it that
helps and then also indicate where you
are when we ask the question in your
behalf so that Spencer who knows who to
address his answer to and it's not just
a general mass
okay very long term very large-scale
biomimicry please welcome to the
southern end of salmon nation Spencer BB
Stewart you look great with Janine
beignets written all over your face
thank you very much I monitor course and
even little intimidated I want all of
you to listen carefully so that you can
tell me afterwards where these ideas are
right and where they're wrong and how we
can make them better this is really a
great moment when i started ecotrust
about almost 15 years ago and met with
stuart and described what I wanted to do
try to build a movement around
integrating social economic and
environmental concerns I got about a
minute and a half or two minutes into
the conversation and he said I get it I
think your motto should be get rich slow
I think that's a great motto I love that
and Stuart I wanted to report to you
that it's working
it's really really really slow the long
poor now it's getting really tedious I'm
getting impatient and if any value smart
Silicon Valley people have any good
ideas about how to get rich quick I'd
really like to talk with you after the
after this discussion here so I've got a
few heroes in addition to Stewart
Brandon and Ryan feelin and Paul Hawken
and half the people here Kevin Kelly
Janine bedias now you got the idea there
she's a but produced this wonderful book
a few years ago called biomimicry and
aggregated all those great individuals
Backson with with agriculture in Kansas
and the guys that are venting things
material science people out of spider
webs and slug slime and taking abalone
shell and figuring out what we know
about ceramics and making them out of
common materials at life temperature and
pressure instead of the heat treat and
beat but she brought all those ideas
together in one place and I love the way
she described it nature as model nature
as measure nature is meant in effect
said you know all the design problems
that we struggle with have already been
solved the result of three and a half
billion years of successful trial error
experiment is what we've got and we
should be paying attention another hero
I guess probably to all of us is Jane
Jacobs who's written all kinds of
wonderful books the life and death of
great American cities she came on the
board of ecotrust for several years in
the mid-90s about the time she was
working on this book called the nature
of economies it's a spectacularly
important and good book that I find just
it almost impossible to read
it's really i don't know Kevin what you
thought it there's all kinds of good
stuff in there but it's really hard to
get at it but the premise of the book
what she said right up front the
beginning was that human beings exist
wholly within nature as part of natural
order in every respect and if you can't
buy that you really won't agree with
anything that she says and if you can't
buy that you probably won't agree with
anything that i have to say tonight as
well you know it's the same same as
nature always bats last and by the way
owns the stadium or the global economy
is a wholly owned subsidiary of the
global ecosystem it's that idea the book
is God let me say a few things from the
book rich the nature of development I'm
convinced that Jane Jacobs that economic
life is ruled by processes and
principles that we didn't invent and
can't transcend whether we like it or
not and that the more we learn of these
processes and the better we respect them
the better our economies will get along
working along with natural principles of
development expecting ability and
correction people can create economies
that are more reliably prosperous than
those that we have now and that are also
more harmonious with the rest of nature
I love that reliable prosperity is that
what we're looking for what development
principles she talked about
differentiation emerging out of
generality and it's actually really
elegant quite beautiful differentiations
become generalities from which further
differentiations emerge development is
an open-ended process which creates
complexity and diversity by repeating
and repeating and repeating simple
process staggering diversity results she
talked about how development is depends
on co developments that line but a web
economic developments don't come out of
thin air they have lineages and
pedigrees the same as other forms of
natural
this is some ways the best the best of
all economic development she said isn't
a matter of imitating nature rather
economic development is a matter of
using the same universal principles that
the rest of nature uses the alternative
isn't to develop some other way some
other way doesn't exist economic
development is a virgin version of
natural development so we got to watch
it a little bit with biomimicry it isn't
the matter that we just need to copy
nature we are nature and we either work
in a way that's consistent with natural
systems and processes or we're going
down the drain and the other part that I
love is that systems make themselves up
as they go along ecosystems economies
weather languages all complex adaptive
systems do that creative self
organization is uncommanded
unpredictable future I like that because
I I can't figure it all out and the only
way I can make things work is just to
jump in and try something and see if it
works and fiddle with a little bit and
then try something else and plum that's
the best part of all that hero that I
want to mention for one great quote
earth first I've never met him he you
know did the national college campus
tour really got people riled up and at
the end of one of his talks young coed
in the back got up and sort of despair
and said what one thing can I do one
thing that I can do that would be most
important to help the environment and he
said he
I love that that's what native people do
that's what real economic development
takes that's what biomimicry takes
you've got to be in a place and try to
understand a place over the time to
begin to even begin to understand how we
might want to develop I think it's a
title bio mimic or die or collapse maybe
is what did your diamond is going to
tell us I wanted to do one other thing
it's maybe it's because I spend a lot of
time with Native people up and down the
coast whenever you meet a native person
a native elder in particular um they
always want to tell you their exact and
full name and who their mother was and
who their father was and what clan their
part of Beaver clan is different than a
Raven clan is different than an Eagle
clan and what village they're from so
you know exactly kind of where they fit
the scheme of things and i think it's a
it's a part of respect you know when you
say it's good to know you know you begin
to know who a person is by that by that
description um where do I come from I
think the most important once in my life
was growing up in Oregon following a
lovely birds of prey and from Asia about
10 11 through college I practice file
that was my first bird Tia that's a
red-tailed hawk about at six weeks old
and a great springer spaniel named Toby
on the coast of Oregon tio magnificent
bird same red-tail Hawks that you see
right here in the presidio you found the
nest of same red-tailed hawk that pale
meola you know both pollicis what's her
name the front porch and that on the
tower above central park and thousand
dollars putting back up platform so she
could invest again a one wonderful bird
sweet and gentle going and at other
times that tough
as hell like the time she there's cat uh
this is about a four-week-old peregrine
falcon fe is I snatch it from its nest
Cashin river that must have been
nineteen sixty 1960 I guess the
summertime right there were floating
down the red deer river and the 17 foot
grumman can do I think we had a coyote
tied to the bow looks a little weird
sticking out of there but look at that I
of that bird I mean you can tell in a
young organism a young creature you look
in their eye and they have that deep
thanks truck I mean they you really know
they're looking at you when she's
looking this is arctica full-fledged
about three weeks later sitting on the
back of the sofa when I was supposed to
be doing my homework probably fooling
around reading books on birds of prey
and trying to understand the habits and
habitats and life history so that I
could learn to get along with these
birds summer now with arctica I spent
theaters eating care of a ranch property
and the metolius River in central oregon
fixing enough Corral's and irrigating
and chasing horses around is hard to do
when you've only got one hand because I
didn't go anywhere without arctica so I
mean I just thought this was the most
magnificent creature in the world I mean
this is the absolute ultimate expression
of this successful history of evolution
every single feather and that bird is
right everything that bird does is right
and powerful influence was when I run
into a coat and tie proper adult the
people making decisions in in society
and we get talking about it they'd
always ask how did you train that bird
and I just thought that was the
stupidest question I could possibly
imagine how could some dumb
fourteen-year-old kid train a peregrine
falcon the / Grand Falcon you know does
everything have
slowly magnificently has more integrity
and authenticity and does everything
what I suppose he's going to be trained
I had to figure out how to work with
that bird with that bird so it just
seemed like how come people exactly the
wrong question golden eagle nest up on
the john day river there's another one a
wonderful golden eagle you got to kind
of look them right in the eye because
they they can get kind of tough when
you're not paying attention and I wasn't
doing that and what I really like to do
is be out in a place like this taking
pictures with an old view camera that's
what I feel most comfortable doing and
it the way I sort of grew up is just
with these birds trying to learn and
understand how they worked and I think
that that's why I've spent 30 years as a
conservationist a little that I know
that that boyhood adolescent fet
infatuation charismatic megafauna was
altogether wrong and what I really
should have been looking at and watching
with slime mold because as we all know
from well Stephen johnson's new book on
emergence as slime mold is what's told
us all about how systems and emergent
behavior really works here's this
remarkably undifferentiated organism
that is exactly like all the other
individuals and at some point when the
light and moisture is right they all
aggregate to awful-looking mass and
creep across the forest floor eating
things as they go and then put up a part
and said in spores out to start all over
again and it took us research we always
assume that the only way they could do
that is there had to have one cell that
was a pacemaker that was in charge it
was the hierarchical industrial
system where there's got to be somebody
in charge right and they excrete a
chemical and then everybody else senses
the firm own and they get in line and
off they go well there wasn't any
pacemaker the undifferentiated cells
each on their own said okay things are
right let's go and that's I guess having
a lot of influence now Kevin know was
that what fast cheap and out of control
was about something like that so
ecotrust we started in 1991 we've got an
idea call it salmon nation and I think
part of his sort of a mythology of place
we got to get in people's head we got to
get people change the way they think we
got to get away from the industrial
model we got to get back to the slime
mold emergent complex adaptive system
model the bio mimic model the J&J
Jacob's model we've got three basic
goals we tried this amination you know a
place defined by where the salmon go and
a society and economy that's built on
the particular characteristics of that
environmentally defined place an ancient
idea about a revolutionary idea and
instead of building states and economies
on the political lines of war and
colonialism the straight lines of county
and state and province why wouldn't we
define the place around environmental
lines and think of the people who live
there as citizens of that place as they
have been for 12,000 years and why don't
we let the find ways in which to
encourage the people who live in those
places to take care of it leave it off a
little better than they found it we also
in addition to try to articulate that
idea and mapping and describing the
place to some successes support tangible
successes on the ground and then we're
trying to build constituencies of place
as constituencies for change we play 3
sort of roles in kind of reverse order
catalyst is the idea describing salmon
nation most of what we do is actually
brokerage and we're simply trying to
bring those
citizens of salmon nation who are trying
to threw themselves their their
neighborhood organizations their
watershed councils their businesses and
local governments and tribes trying to
improve social economic and
environmental conditions we try to bring
them the same resources that are part of
globalization access increasing access
to gene capital and then sometimes we
just get bored and impatient discharge
ahead and do something ourselves that's
what we do as sort of those three kinds
of things now what I was going to try to
tonight was talk about just one
particular be forests and forestry and a
model of biome it was quite different
than the model that's out there right
now early on at ecotrust we we thought
well there may be the research a thing
as a temperate rainforest I've been
spent 13 years working on forest I want
to get home I wanted to stay home and so
we looked at temperate rainforest and it
turns out they occur in this relative
band a combination of temperature and
precipitation where it's too wet to be
temperate or grassland er desert at too
cold too cold to be tropical to be at
Tyga or tendra temperate rainforests
coastal temperate rainforests are
actually quite rare they were scattered
about this is where they were maybe a
thousand years ago the biggest area of
coastal temperate rainforest in the
world is in North America it's only
about 200 million acres altogether
worldwide second biggest area southern
coast of Chile and then there's there's
some still on the South Island on the
west coast of New Zealand Tasmania there
was some that's now all gone crane and
Georgia and then southwest Norway
western ireland and scotland and there
was a little tiny piece up there in
iceland
and I think that's maybe where Jared
Diamond talks about the Norsemen getting
in there cutting down all the trees and
eating their dogs and vanishing at the
area of tropical forest over half of its
gone and when we zoom in a little bit
more on that done the largest one on the
North America there you have the coast
there you have the temperature and there
you have the moisture coastal temperate
rainforests from right about there
afognak the eastern part of Kodiak
Island right down the coast of around
Prince William Sound and the lost coast
and down into southeast Alaska in
British Columbia and then we include the
redwoods as well think there's any place
in the world where you can go 2,000
miles north south across with addicts
all those latitudinal lines still have
so little variation in temperature from
a mean average of you know 55 degrees or
so there it is what it looked like about
a hundred million acres redwoods down
here the it's defined by 80 inches or
more of rain a year relative absence out
there for relative absence of pic fire
therefore the trees old and they grow
big they have the principal disturbance
not fire not big open destruction are
small arms and it's Apache disturbance
lands recourses snow avalanches to pachi
mosaic of disturbance
because they live so long and they get
so big it's they have more standing
biomass and any other ecosystem if any
kind by a magnitude of three to five
fold I mean three to five fold more
standing biomass then then then troppo
the richest tropical rainforest so we
know something about the history
remember rain for from from apollon
diagrams you know pollen when they get
into a wetland or a bog thousands and
thousands of years and you can take core
samples in the bogs and and get the
distribution of the different species
over time so this is kind of the picture
of the coastal temperate rain for of
North America over time that's 50,000
years and a creation and deglaciation
interglacial periods you know this
region in that period of top from
parkland and sort of a mountain more
alpine forest type to Tundra to spruce
and pine and only in the last really
five as it become dominated by the
species that we see today western red
cedar western Sitka spruce red alder and
big leaf maple along the streams this is
a little more of the detail in the last
15,000 years for the Olympic Peninsula
puget r off the coast of oregon and so
there we are own house neat large scale
that large scales at ferry as long a
time as that force has it and if you
think about it red cedar they can get to
be 15 feet almost a hundred and a
thousand twelve hundred sometimes 15 so
that represents five generations of red
cedar this is a young forest
some as I mentioned you know
characterized troll diversity age class
diversity there may be young seedlings
that are a year or two in the and then
the canopy that some trees maybe both
and everything in between and great
species diversity in great productivity
there's a patch of old-growth doug fir
dead and dying you know western red
cedar will live for six or seven hundred
years the top starts to die because it
can't pull up the moisture and you get
those candelabra dead topped up and it
will stand and slowly die for two or
three four hundred years and then after
all of it is altogether dead it'll stand
as this dead live snag for for three or
four hundred years and will fall down
and take 500 years to decay intimate
relationship with streams with the ocean
in the marine environment indeed some
scientists are saying that a good amount
of the variance phosphorus and nitrogen
or marine come for the marine
environment and come in salmon they come
up the streams that are picked up by the
Bears and dragged back to the forest
we've looked pretty carefully at the
patterns of natural disturbance and a
whole watershed basis I won't get into
the detail on that I wish I knew more
about the history of the of people in
this region coevolution quarterly this
is coevolution millennia Lee because
this forest co-evolved from as you can
tell the last five ten thousand years
indigenous people have occupied this
part of the world for at least 10,000
maybe 12,000 years and of course in
those glacial periods when the ice was
just the Bering Land Bridge was exposed
and apparently Asian people came across
epson one or several waves and those
were the original people presumably came
down the coast different language groups
in this region for lineal societies in
the north and by lineal in the mid-south
they were very stratified society well
taken care of elite and a large purse
and there were slaves and the culture
seemed to be organized more around food
and social systems and around what we
think of as a political system the food
they had permanent settlements they had
apparently the densest populations of
hunter-gatherer forger people of
anywhere in the world at any time in the
history of the world presumably because
in part of the extraordinary abundance
of fish and shellfish and food but the
food came in waves and came didn't come
all at once so they had these permanent
settlements and these big wonderful
cedar of longhouses that would live for
400 years but then they had to go out
with big canoes and they had wood
technology for at least 10,000 years and
had to be organized around the control
and access of those individual pulses of
food so extraordinary art extraordinary
ritual and ceremony and really a unique
in in the world we mapped the patterns
of change first European connections
were what mid 1700s we know the jet Guns
Germs and Steel story most of the course
died of epidemics and smallpox and so
forth we D cultured them big time big
scale a whole variety of dreadful ways
this left slide shows the status of
forests and the relatively small apart
in the mid coast to be left intact and
the middle slide shows where salmon and
steelhead populations have gone extinct
pretty similar pattern from the south
north and then this slide our native
language groups those are the numbers of
speakers still living of each of the
distinct of 63 language groups and the
paler colors are the ones where there
it's gone or there's just a handful
usually of 60 year plus individuals that
speak the language so coevolution and
devolution in the region this is the
basic model for forestry that's
developed in the industrial age in the
last hundred years it would be hard to
imagine a system that would be more
completely to the nature of this place I
mean it's the opposite of biomimicry
this is an industrial tree plantation
this is the American tree farm idea this
is even aged where the natural forest is
uneven-aged this is single species I
usually have a genetically improved Doug
Fir where the forest is of many species
this is a single age class where the
forest was multiple and is very simple
in terms of its structural complexity
and its interaction with the streams so
clear-cut slash pile Nature doesn't / by
all the letters get it over the forest
burn coast of temperate rainforests 80
inches of rain through the earth doesn't
burn much plant a different species
usually off-site genetically improved as
if three and a half billion years of
evolution hadn't created seeds that
might survive best in that particular
place and then I'll chemicals to control
competing vegetation sprain fertilizer
from helicopters and then clear-cut
again about age 45 20 year old even-aged
stands 5 year old stand about a 55 year
old Stan
it'll be clear cut and look like this
we've all seen pictures of the result
it's very efficient you can if you're
thinking in terms income statement
versus a balance sheet you had a lot of
income net present value is pretty good
you got a lot of trees you want to make
money cut them all down make sense you
can get a lot of 20 25 log trucks off a
clear-cut site like that in a day kind
of looks like that there's another model
though bio mimic and some of the lessons
come from different forest types this is
pine a little bit of Doug Fir western
larch and northeastern Oregon and the
interior in a dryer site more level
ground where individual tree selection
has been more common a little easier
although it's usually been a kind of
hydrating take the best reason leave the
poorest these this a guy named Jerry
mogera and his son Sam he's a forester
and a logger and he just finished
logging that whole stand about two
months before that he left the good
trees he encouraged diversity he left
the snags and when the neighboring
Rancher came over and wanted to cut down
that large or tamarac snag to make fence
posts out of it he said sorry we like
snags and we leave those and that hole
is affiliated woodpecker that was
nesting an active then and that larch
and that right there is an old
red-tailed hawks nest with a great
successful pair of great gray owls two
relatively rare and unusual who
successfully nested and that is a about
a four-week-old fledgling great gray owl
you can increase diversity habitat
structure while life values the
aesthetics and do a little bit of
cutting if you do it and a bio mimicked
with the patterns of nature sort of way
you can use those same logging equipment
individual tree selection you can thin
like this
about 50 year old stand of hemlock and
begin to get a nice second can of lower
ground cover of natural regeneration you
get a lot of you get sometimes two
thousand seedlings per acre if you just
open up a little bit of light because
that's what those trees do they're
adapted to grow on a or you can exceed
bed in low light their shade tolerant
and they'll do just fine those are
spruce and hemlock seedlings that's what
a forest that's managed with a bio mimic
pattern looks like one month after the
logging was finished it made money it
left the best trees at last diversity of
species and structures and age classes
that's what a bio mimicked natural
pattern of forest management might look
like from the year sort of a little
patch cut the way winters the wind storm
might do that's what the land about a
mile away looks like I just happen to be
flying by and it'll beat up airplane
with a little digital poke my camera out
the window to see those two comparisons
about a month ago we've done some
modeling on a natural forest management
model and an industrial model over a
hundred year period of time and on a
typical second-growth forest under the
two different regimes the industrial
model sort of maintains its value
maintains a really low standing volume
of wood because its young small short
trees again get clear-cut at age 45 the
natural model is worth more market value
it produces more harvest more wood it
produces more cash it reproduces more
cumulative cash it produces more it
produces more biodiversity it produces
cleaner water and better salmon runs it
captures more carbon and reduces makes
its contribution to reducing global
climate change
but in the typical economic terms net
present value is about eighty percent of
the industrial model if you've got a
bunch of trees and you want to have it
worth as much as possible soon you cut
them all down and that's what's
happening of course so that's a little
bit here's the story the coastal
temperate rainforest a little bit of the
history and the people that devolve
there and a little bit of the recent
history with the patterns of economic
development around the forest and I
think there's other ways of going about
it I wanted to tell you a couple stories
and then I'll be done Stuart's been here
Ryan Phelan has been here Paul Hawken
has been here this is a story about the
kitlope river when we did the early
mapping we found that actually there was
only one large coastal temperate
rainforest intact a whole watershed in
all in north america the best ones are
in British Columbia they were about 25
over a hundred thousand hectares in size
it's about 250,000 acres one left and
that was the kitlope we went there in
1989 it was Heisler native people who
had lived there for ten twelve thousand
years and there's still signs of their
historic market we asked them what this
kit
River Valley of which was part of it and
they said well we don't end the login
with for 280 kilometers of roads that
were all map the orange survey stakes
were out they were the high slit didn't
particularly want to see it logged it
was still had all the salmon runs and
they fished subsistence fish tuned in
this area still today but they said what
our problem is is we're not sure there's
going to be a high slit people in
another generation because we had six
teenage high slit kids commit suicide in
this last summer in a village of 7 or 50
people drug abuse the alcohol abuse this
sort of utter despair and the feeling of
not wanting to be a high school and Ian
would kind of overcome so we got busy
and worked with them on on rediscovery
program to get the kids out in the in
the country with with the elders and
over the course of time the isolette
stood firm said we don't want audion in
this area four years later the premiere
and the logging company west fraser
timber company in august of 1994
announced that the entire eight hundred
thousand acre kitlope river from the
mountaintops and the ice down to the
estuary would be protected these are
high slit indian kids in a traditional
canoe last august in a celebration of
the 10th anniversary coming into the
ceremony to be welcomed and the story
here is around the high sloth of what
they wanted to name this place it was a
new kind of protected area that
respected the natives interest and
there's a co management agreement and
they'll be able to continue to use the
area the high slit took forever to
figure out what they wanted to call it
the government called it the kitlope
heritage Conservancy the heist laughed
for about a year of discussion said no
no we're going to call it hoosh to our
shoe new Yun Jie's said well what in the
world is that hoosh to wash do is the
their name for that place they have that
very particular place the land of milky
blue waters is glacial in the spring and
the water is just turquoise
new Yun Jie's sacred stories that go
with that place so it's the land of
milky blue waters and the city to go of
that place and sacred stories of course
are the ones that accumulated over
12,000 years of continuous occupation
that said this is what you can do and
this is what you shouldn't do this is
how you can live well in this place this
is another place in the coast of British
Columbia there really wasn't much left
in southern bc we mapped all the
watersheds on Vancouver Island there
were 95 coastal temperate rainforest
watersheds in Vancouver Island over
5,000 hectares in size about 12,000
acres three of them were in an area
called clack would sound crackle sounds
on the west coast of Vancouver Island
just an absolutely beautiful mix of
islands and beaches and rocky shore and
inland bays and mountains and rivers I'm
about a million acres in size National
Geographic went up there in September of
1990 to look at in an hour to do an
article about temperate rainforests in
part in our encouragement and this is
what they saw that was a National
Geographic sort of folded out about
three times that's the escalante and
that's a clear cut that's about 15 miles
long from the rocky shore to the ridge
top was nineteen ninety seems a little
extreme as a bio mimic model this is 19
what is this that's 2000 and thank you
2003 National Geographic went back to a
clock would sound and wrote a story
about that place and waxed eloquent
about what they called Oh economy
when eight hundred protesters the
logging were arrested this biggest civil
disobedience in Canadian history and
finally the logging companies were
stopped the key watersheds were
protecting the native people got into
the decision making a new model for
logging around biomechanical they
evolved and the economy began to
emphasize sports fishing as well as
commercial fishing aquaculture whale
watching fly fishing great and in a
period of time of you know a little over
ten years it really did transition if we
need very large scale very long term
biomimicry for change actually when you
get up and say wait a minute this
industrial economy doesn't work and get
serious about it this is the kind of
logging that's going on up there now
it's a esok forest resources which we
help to finance the joint day child news
tribal council the local native people
and whereas are the natives have the
majority interest and they're doing that
kind of patch cutting to copy nature
there's the middle beach lodge when we
first started up there in 1990 everybody
said well what are we going to do for an
economy the tourism season is about two
months is pouring down rain the rest of
time what are we going to do middle
beach lodge the last few years has got
ninety five percent occupancy 12 months
a year this is a five hour drive from
victoria and a windy one love this place
they build it so you can in the rare
moment when it's sunny you can go out in
the beach most the time it's raining and
you can sit by the fire and read a book
and they sell winter wind storms because
that's really cool you can sit right
there on the deck and watch the waves
come crashing over the deck it's a 150
bucks a night it's not cheap so it's
interesting what can happen if we just
sort of rethink
start over again bio mimic I don't want
to talk about this ecotrust uh one of
the things we did was start
environmental bank because we figured if
there are people and businesses of
trying to improve fishing and farming
and forest practices and we needed to
have a source for information and
capital to help him do it so we did that
and it's a million dollar bank now it's
making money and they've made about 300
loans with their nonprofit affiliate and
they're doing pretty well we also use
biomimicry and sort of modeled the
restoration of 100 year old warehouse in
Northwest Portland this is an example of
actor rather than broker we get tired of
paying rent and wanted to bring our dogs
to the office so we bought a block in
downtown Portland and did a two year 12
million dollar restoration and cleaned
it all up and repointed the brick and
rebuilt the parapet and spent a million
and a half dollars on seismic steel and
that's what it looks like today and
we've got 25 tenets resident a retail
and commercial tenants there's for
profits there's nonprofits there's
government there's private sector
there's a conference center we've had
million and a half people visit the
building in three years and last year
there are about 400 events in the
conference center 20,000 people on all
kinds of themes and we discharge or get
in rent right but it's been a great
convening place and the ecosystem
principles were diversity which every
big building and of downtown has but no
connectedness you know find the edges
the Eco tones so it's open and no or as
few as possible impermeable surfaces so
people can going to interact farmers
market in the summertime and we have a
good time there so on the last one if we
think this kind of biomimicry why don't
we just do it so we created a private
equity fund called ecotrust forest LLC
and closed in the first ten million at
the end of December and I've got seven
investors including ecotrust that are
individuals individual trusts family
trusts Family Foundation's and family
investment companies who are putting up
some money we're buying second-growth
forest that's one that we were hoping to
buy out on the Olympic Peninsula but
we're too late and that's what it looks
like now because somebody else got it we
did get this piece is up just a small
piece of thousand acres and that's what
it looks like after the logging that we
completed in in in October a little
patch cut I'm finding a little patch cut
little finning little thinning over here
we're already about 5% cash on cash in
about eight months time and we took a
very small percentage of the
merchantville timber this was classic
kind of leftover logged over beat up
thousand acres of land right but we're
leaving the best trees we're leaving the
more natural mix of species and it will
take time but but I think it will work
we tried to get Warren Buffett excited
about it and I sent me back a note and
it said trees grow slow so there's a
whole bunch of ways of I didn't have a
picture of the neo-cons in their
meetings or george bush and doing I
don't know what I just thought this was
a good picture I don't know what we're
doing right now is a nation here and
around the world but it feels sort of
like that to me I think there's another
way to go and it's got to be built on a
whole different way of way societies
think you know there's what they call
orange societies and Apple societies and
orange societies are all segmented they
separate economics and ecology I like
this industrial model for forestry and
there's another model it's an apple
society where it's all integrated in
whole and connected and we think that's
the way to go that's what James was
talking about we think we can build a
conservation economy by addressing you
know economic vitality full equity and
environmental restoration we could
measure it in fairly simple ways this is
the Klamath River to Falls ago when the
temperature water dab drawdowns where
high temperatures went up in 60,000 fall
chinook salmon
beautiful big bright silver salmon died
all at once so we know things are not
well ultimately we gotta figure measure
the way people thinking about this and
the extent to which they're changing the
way they think we're hard at it kind of
Allah just trying to invent a new
mythology of place a mythology that will
guide us and our relationship with each
edge with each other and with nature and
that's my whole story and I'm sticking
to it
we get the lights up a little bit we
have questions coming up front here now
is a good time C Mon could you bring the
lights up a little back in the back
there so we can all see each other thank
you when you were starting on that volim
Center my pleasure of looking at that
old building with you a couple times and
we were thinking about my other things
most buildings last about 60 years and
then they're gone but actually any
building can live indefinitely and some
do you know castles and stuff or
buildings that get declared historical
what's your long-term time frame
building of that building we just saw it
was all about the life of the place the
interesting thing was not the the green
you know materials the way we're
managing water and light and air the
interesting thing was really that
ecosystem model and the way people
interact so I think it's more about the
community of tenant and the way they
might continue to interact over time
it's been I think if you end up with the
wrong population of population that
doesn't share the basic values we tried
to get tenants clustered around a
diverse both retail and office
private-public for-profit nonprofit but
they're clustered around forestry
fishing food and farms green building
and socially responsible investing so
the bank will make you a loan or take an
eco deposit there's some foundations of
makeup grants and there's a social
responsible investment fund one of the
ones that I think makes the list and
this progressive investment management
so you've got clusters but so I think if
it's a live time but if socially it
starts to die the rents aren't going to
be there somebody else going
this is baloney we're going to those it
and go up a sort of interesting thing
that came up many people about this but
there's a the building is on half a
block and that parking lot and the bios
whales are also and a half a block so we
actually have a 280 x 13 story block in
a very valuable area and so i think
could we do some time when we get time a
really contemporary really elegant
really beautiful building and if the old
historic and the new could play off each
other there'd be new life anyway we'll
see you're a close student of jane
jacobs and she of you by now I'd notice
and she rethought cities not just
American cities but cities in general in
the relation buildings and cities which
is exceptionally interesting in Portland
and then between the city and the region
around it and then a city and basically
its hold while region how does that play
out for you guys well we were working
mostly in the rural areas down the coast
we are trying to improve environment and
improve the economy and we got talking
with Jane Jacobson said you can't really
that you know the people in Willow
pouvais down the coast they can't do it
all by themselves they need to connect
explicitly directly with the technology
the capital the markets in the city
that's where development is really
happening so actually she she said I'd
write about this you guys are doing it
we were working for example with
oystermen and Willow pub a saying you
guys are shipping this off and these
were they called number eight the mason
jars these big ugly disgusting looking
things looks like a high school
experiment you know and formaldehyde and
you know people young people
those things if you get into the
high-end restaurants and do small ones
and do fresh and do it you know on the
shell and so forth you're going to get
you know you'll grow it shorter period
of time they're going to triple the
price anyway so we were working with
restaurants and retailers and so forth
and trying to make those explicit
connections so it sounded it sounded
really bright and I think it is true the
ability to produce environmentally sound
goods and services in the country would
food fish whatever it might be services
at tourism with the demand in the cities
so it's almost a framework condition for
salmon nation we've got to find a
synergistic mutually reinforcing
relationship between rural and urban and
today it's pretty it's pretty sad it's
pretty rough you know blue state it
publican democrat very divisive but i
think it's all there and and we continue
to nurse that in a food and farms
program the forestry program the
marketing of greenwood into the city and
green building and so forth and we just
have to do a lot more but either you
talked a lot of this is really a forest
story you told the night a wonderful and
there's a lot of stuff i hadn't figured
out before and one question from a
person who might identify themselves is
what is hindering the logging companies
from using the bio memory model the most
visit forest service or short-term gains
economics what's the problem I think
it's the economic model I think it's
Wall Street I think its quarterly
earnings I think there's a net present
value I think it's a short-term it's
remote its investors who don't live
there and don't see the negative side of
what they're doing the biggest shift in
forest land ownership in the US over the
last 20 years has been about twenty
percent of the u.s. forest land
ownership going from industrial
integrated forest products
Bunny's to what are called teemo's
timberland investment management
organizations that own 15 billion
dollars probably close to 20 billion now
and some 12 million acres of forest land
and those teemo's timo get it it's not
forest it's timber our bio mimic model
was how about treating it like a forest
instead of just trees this tee mo is in
all of them are fixed term funds they
are 10 or 12 year funds so buy wholesale
log hard sell retails divide it up and
then the all the incentives are in 10
carry on the organizers so when you exit
and get out towards the end you make you
know divided up twenty percent of the
profits from the partners the 10-year
horizon and a forest that's why we saw
the history and inevitably if you use a
an income statement approach instead of
a balance sheet approach and you look at
how much money how much income can i
generate fast you cut it all down and
that's what's happening if you use a
balance sheet and both build wealth you
will grow the income in our all analysis
is you'll get more wood more money more
jobs better water more potential tourism
but it's going to take some time and
Warren Buffett in quite there yet so
we're looking for our economics of
patients react exist you we I mean I
just I think we need the consumer demand
i mean there's an FSC certified wood out
there that's the standard for the
ecological model a for stewardship
council and there's about 100 million
acres worldwide that's certified now FSC
the last of the dinosaurs are in the
Pacific Northwest they don't want to go
that way they've got their own SFI model
which is maybe an improvement and there
is I mean I shouldn't sound so negative
in country because there's a lot of
improvement
the landscape and different ownerships
but I think we need consumers and
citizens and people saying hey how can
we make this better and if I'm building
a house or need some wood I'm gonna make
damn sure it comes from FSC certified
force and when I go a restaurant and I
were asked for salmon i'm going to make
damn sure it's wild not front this is
questioning from paul i assume Hawkin
about the heislers that you okay can you
explain how you got the Heisler
re-engaged at the kill hope be less
modest he says we listen to I mean it
was is actually easy it's funny when I
go around it you know there's all this
there's this article going around on the
internet called environmentalism is dead
and there's a lot of evidence for that
I'm just kind of one E and it's been
kind of big scary message and a lot of
negative and pessimistic and abstract
and full of data and contrary and leaves
people feeling kind of overwhelmed and
too busy to deal with it and looking for
some more hope and I talked to some of
the environmentalists now and they say
but we just have to get our message out
better we have to articulate the idea
better we have to you know learn from
the marketing gurus and so forth and
frankly my reaction is that is the same
as what Tom Friedman told george bush in
the editorial what about three weeks ago
before the europe trip and it said read
my ears that's the most important thing
that george bush could do to build
relationships is europe is to listen and
i don't think we need to tell people
more what they have to do I think we
have to find people where they are and
what their needs are and what they're
trying to do everybody's trying to
improve their lives in their livelihood
it's all the same across the board
listen I mean I that's our sort of basic
principles start by spelled it out a
little bit awesome yeah there you
listened what happened you would happen
to them
well the first trip I mean we we did the
mapping we found this place I like
anything about it we called around to
the experts in British Columbia the
scientists and the Ministry of forest
people and so forth nobody know anything
about the kid hope they never heard of
it I have no idea what you're talking
about kitlope River Sidwell it's the
biggest on log watershed in bc well we
don't know even know where it is or what
it is so so we're going to go through
and look at her who lives there we
called the kitimat village council guy
picks up the phone turns out to be the
chief guy named Gerald Amos he said
we've been doing some mapping and we
really interested in the kit open can we
come up and visit there are three of us
that foolishly I talked to float plane
pilot at a Whistler into flying us up
there the other guys were bringing the
food I won't get into all the details is
on story here we were totally unprepared
and we got dropped off at the beach at
the mouth of the river there there were
grizzly bears and salmon run everywhere
it was totally cool but the these
Heisler three elders I said we're going
to go in there and such and such a time
and we'll just meet you there it is
about we got dropped off about three
days beforehand um and I don't know why
we thought they are actually going to
show up and it's basically really stupid
but they did and I just went fishing
with him they were up there fishing I
just went up and pulled the net and
pulled fish out of nets and watch him
shoot the seal you know when he got in
started eating salmon I was sort of
admiring this seal swimming around the
river that's cool big big pool of blood
floating down the river is it will he
fix that problem
but we camped with him we talked we SAT
around the fire and he's you know they
taught and I said what you know what do
you guys need what do you think what do
you want and the typical thing is you
create a campaign you go there and you
recruit them to be part of your campaign
and they've seen every ISM you know that
we've had to offer for 400 years and
there hasn't been an ism at all that
denim has done them any good ever
industrialism environmentalism or
whatever it's always somebody else
telling them what to do you've lived
there forever they know what to do just
support them so we just there is a very
long week we did the map the global map
of temperate rainforest showed North
America was most important we did the BC
inventory for right I think it was like
fifteen thousand dollars we looked at
every image every year watershed up the
coast we have the data said this one you
know we looked at the satellite images
we talked to everybody this was the most
important one about the time the
ministry of force of the logging company
figured out that we were onto something
they said oh yeah but we're just going
to log part of it and will give all the
jobs to Iceland so forth we produced a
careful scientific assessment of the
whole watershed itself and had that
ahead of them in terms of species list
and stuff before the company was able to
do that they were going to log this to
the first summer it was an interesting
piece problems therapist because you've
got to move fast to stay ahead of the
logging company in the government in
many cases the provincial government you
got to move slow because if you of
course the native groups the First
Nations folks too fast then that's just
the same old story for them so how do I
dance that yeah that's a good question I
mean that's just that's the strategy
that's the all-night conversations
that's the do we go like hell right now
I mean that I went to several meetings
with the premiere in the minister of
force with Heisler elvers where they
said you're going to have to shoot us
we're going to be on the beach with our
guns there's going to be blood in the
sand you are not login the kitlope okay
we had decided when those moments might
be I mean together I wasn't going to say
hey come on you guys tell them that you
they'll shoot you ever come in here but
I mean I think the key thing was the
Heisler woman's society for rediscovery
the woman and the village said dammit we
are going to do something about these
kids and when we work for them over four
or five is in about eight years and we
got you know one week in two weeks
sessions with about 15 kids in each one
with the elders back in the kit hope
around the lake they'd never been there
haven't seen it it's 80 kilometres down
that long fewer and those kids started
to hear the stories and see the forest
and see the salmon spawning then seeing
that this little village they were all
of a sudden the great moment for me in
the whole history of it was a Canadian
film company did a documentary about the
kitlope and they interviewed one of the
girls Robinson about 15 years old in the
rediscovery camp and she looked right in
the camera and said I am proud to be
Haislip that was for me you know the
most powerful piece of the whole thing
they became you know they found their
identity you know how they're connected
with history and where they're going to
go in the future they say by God we're
going to get control of the situation
and I you know we did up we did I'll
betcha we did 20 publications we did
posters we worked with several other
organizations we did inventory as we did
the science we did conferences and
meetings and got the local people
together and each time fortunately we
were just sort of one step ahead an
event the key moment was at a public
meeting I wasn't there ken Margolis and
our staff was there it was a whole bunch
of Heisler elders and youth must have
been about June of 1994 and the woman
for loggers group and the loggers the
labor union and the mill owners and west
fraser and the west fraser guy after a
conversation the morning got up and said
here's the deal we can only log about
twenty percent of the forest no which
means all the bottom land all the big
trees next to the river and we'll only
employ Haislip people with that Oh
and I mean remember margolis calling me
and said we might have lost the whole
thing right here I'd had just gone down
the tube they just made this offer
nobody expected it BAM everybody broke
for lunch they came back and Louise bar
Betty got up one of the woman hi some
people did language training and she
said I don't think you understand this
is not about jobs this is about our
survival this is about our people this
is about our identity this is about who
we are this is not about employment we
know about him working in the mills
that's never Denison and then a young
kid about 14 got up and said I've been
in the kit hope you're not log in the
kiddo we don't care how many jobs you're
going to hand out I'd rather be their
attention fish on my own and living kind
of a rich subsistence and then you know
about all I so I got up one after an
hour just like the west fraser I mean
they were it was good of him I mean they
they went they said okay we give up they
walked they had the rights to cut it
they'd spent a lot of money they needed
wood for their mills it's a privately
held company and Hank Ketchum said you
know he actually a later an interview
Ian Gill and he wrote an article now
runs ecotrust Canada he said why did you
walk away from the kid lobe he said well
wasn't cuz the environmentalists and it
wasn't because of the Indians because we
deal with every place we go there's
environmental sand Indians and big trees
and salmon runs and the same old stuff
but when we looked at your maps and the
global status and the BC inventory and
the data we don't want to cut the only
remaining big pristine rainforest left
in the world where you go
so there was a lot but probably should
we should document it more carefully but
it was I mean the basic is the rate the
regular way is you can launch a campaign
and you do the so-called grassroots
organizing get everybody signed up right
the Senators and you make it happen you
force it down the throat and basically
what we did was 180 degrees you know it
was just what I talked about it was now
you were a Peace Corps volunteer to
tender age where where were your peace
corps volunteer I was in on the north
coast of Honduras doing artisanal
fisheries and dugout canoes with
Garifuna so did that bend your twig in
that part of it meet you yeah I was self
sequence of birds and under that hood
behind the view cameras I didn't really
want have much to do with people and I
had a pretty clear choice of either
either going to photo/ariel equipment
repair school in the army and Fort
Monmouth New Jersey the height of
Vietnam in 1968 or sound like cannon
fodder was a shorthand or go to the
Peace Corps and work in fisheries
programs and I think I'll take the
ladder and ended up in this wonderful
little village of these terrific you
know black African by a heritage but
different people and we paddled out
through the surf of the middle of night
and when 10 12 miles 50 miles offshore
and hand lined and fish and we help
those fish traps and lobster traps and
sharp things and a little bit bigger
boats in the ice and so forth and it
didn't do any good so I think I got it
without the Vietnam War there would be
no ecotrust desiring ha without the
Vietnam War there would be no ecotrust
yeah I'd probably be out doing
photography I don't know but it did make
me think about you know what that
there's an interesting piece that we
have a wheel way over time everybody
want to get out of here they said when
you go down there the village there's
nobody else neither white guys around
there no peace where volunteers in these
villages so it's all by myself I didn't
that learned a little French and college
I didn't speak Spanish they've done the
three month thing so I could you know
boy obvious um it was really pathetic so
go in and take a look at the socio
economics of these villages were you
going to be working and figure out where
the money comes from and where the food
comes from and where the water comes
from if there is any water and I did
this kind of there was a standard fruit
company dock at lesabre and they
employed a lot of people actually these
guys for the Marino people and as you
went out in the villages four villages
down about 20 miles in a kind of direct
arithmetic a gradient from those wage
jobs at standard fruit company you had
more and more of the traditional
communities and in San Antonio and bow
fat day you go there and there is no
roads and no connection and no none of
the men worked in the standard Fruit
Company docks and they had great little
adobe houses of thatched roofs and they
decorated with color and paint everybody
had a dugout everybody had a small plot
and a farm kids went to school the men
had one wife's not running all over town
there was a very little alcoholism it
was really kind of a nice intact
traditional and right down to the
proximity the standard Fruit Company and
the every two weeks cash check the
alcoholism the promiscuity the sewage on
the beach I mean it was just Bam Bam Bam
that make quite an impression is you
know there was a intact long slow
developed community and then there's all
of a sudden this cash economy industrial
thing that just completely so that was
interesting you were working on a global
stage released in the sort of the new
world stage for all those years with
Nature Conservancy and Conservation
International and so here's a someone
more global question from Phil wolf
where are you right here in front this
is the what about China question every
lecture on every subject yeah so what
about China question and this is yours
you've got a dustrial economy soaring a
long year after year 12 and a half
percent growth you've got a population
which is
birth rate is leveling but it's still
getting huge there's 300 million Chinese
coming to town from the villages from
the rural areas they're buying up all
our plywood very high prices they're
buying up everybody's steel and iron ore
at very high prices what about China
lots of hard facts reality check what do
they say a pessimist definition of a
pessimist is an optimist with more
information so we got a lot of big ideas
haha but I think you gotta try to make
it real in a very particular place and I
don't pretend to have solution was sort
of instant you know rio de janeiro the
earth summit what 1990 91 92 92 and it
was I mean big time it was biggest
gathering of you know heads of state I
think it ever gathered and it was all
global you know they signed global
biodiversity treaties and Forests
treaties and blah blah blah treaties and
then 10 years later joburg they all got
back together so disappointing I mean
nothing happened they all treated try to
deal everything on the global basis they
never got busy developing the local
regional bioregional leadership and
institutions and incentives and
organizations and initiatives and you
know started making this stuff happen on
the ground so you got something to build
from so I mean I don't know you have to
go to China and I suspect you'd have to
go to different bioregions in China and
you'd have to think about who the people
are there and where they come from and
what the problems are with food labor
and traditional interests and rights and
I mean at least I guess I got busy here
because I thought we needed to add a
little more credibility to the American
voice abroad and
at all that I know if right now so I I
don't have an answer for that had a long
non-answer right we had at least set an
example and we had at least care about
these things and we ought to go over
there and listen to him and see if
there's a way to connect in a way that
addresses their realtor long-term
interest is not going to get served by
this of course now whether or not
there's ways to help them figure it out
I don't know they've been around a lot
longer do we have one of the surprises
in the talk tonight for me was that the
forest you're so busy protecting is
relatively recent really bold in some
respects 15,000 another respect and
that's the timeframe of climate change
among other things and with or without a
whole lot of amelioration we probably
are looking at some significant climate
change decades and centuries how is the
coastal temperate rainforest going to be
with that in waters with changing
climate it could be completely self
buffering and then the species may be
more intact in this particular bioregion
than many others I don't know what you
read on that my read is if that we build
it enough diversity and complexity and
resilience through our management that
the system will adapt and evolve and it
may be that redwoods will march
northward and we welcome on the Redwood
it's a great species the hemlock will
march a little northward the Doug Fir
will start replacing some of the other
things they'll still be forest will mix
of
species well it's interesting because
the other day I hadn't really noticed is
that this 2,000 mile across the latitude
sits at right angles to everything Jared
Diamond talks about right and in that
sense if the climate is shifting a whole
lot of things in the north-south
dimension presumably this corridor on
the west coast would be more capable
because of its continuity of handling
migration north of certain species in
and the gradual transition rather than a
harsh cut off yeah yeah the remember the
forest Clinton he came out to solve the
forest Bob in the northwest shortly
after for a summit pretty insane really
he's amazing tried everybody together
they are always talking openly and
somebody was talking about the March of
deforestation growing across the country
and the industry's our guys were
complaining about spotted owls and one
guy stood up and said the industry isn't
come up against the spotted owl the
industry's come up against the Pacific
Ocean you know I just walked away crawl
across the country that wasn't any more
to to do it was gone I mean I think
that's right i mean this north-south and
this particular ecosystem type brazilian
ecosystems will adapt and change and
people communities and economies will
adapt and change with it i'm even over a
relatively short periods of time but not
good source you know the resilience the
connectedness the basic come you know
intact we can't you know one of the
things this administration trying to do
is legislate the difference between a
wild salmon and the hatchery salmon you
know why restore wolves on people have
dogs we need those wild populations of
salmon they are going extinct in their
southern
you know latitudes and without that
information that bill bryson short
history of everything you know
everything is there is the result of
survival of every progenitor all through
time if we don't have those wild stocks
of salmon adapted to those very
particular places that recovery is going
to be really tough and certainly won't
adapt to you know larger scale climate
change or other kinds of perturbations
well i know i'm not an expert member up
guy and live here thank you one of the
great things about your story is it it's
a long-running in the past and it's got
very long future thank you very much
you